über den umgang der katholischen kirche
mit sexueller gewalt wollen wir sprechen
mit dem sprecher der opferinitiative
eckiger tisch die sich für die
betroffenen einsetzt schönen guten tag
matthias katsch schwimmerin tag aus
offenburg hat sie selbst sind als
schüler in einem jesuitenkolleg
misshandelt worden
die diskussion über sexuelle gewalt in
der katholischen kirche gibt es ja jetzt
schon lange sie selbst haben die sehr
stark vorangetrieben schon in den
letzten zehn 15 jahren worum geht's aus
ihrer sicht jetzt es geht darum dass die
katholische kirche zu lassen muss das
unabhängig und das heißt eben von außen
außerhalb ihrer kontrolle
die verbrechen der vergangenheit
aufgearbeitet werden und das sind zwei
arten von verbrechen das er natürlich
einmal die sexuellen gewalttaten und das
ist zum anderen der umgang mit diesen
gewalttaten das vertuschen und
verheimlichen
und sie tut sich ungeheuer schwer das
sehen wir bis in die jüngste zeit die
kontrolle abzugeben und unabhängig
aufklären und aufarbeiten zu lassen wenn
sie sagen die kirche tut sich extrem
schwer was meinen sie damit
naja wir sehen es ja man gibt
auftragsgutachten in auftrag bei
anwaltskanzleien die für einen selbst
tätig sind und selbst diese gutachten
ist man anschließend nicht bereit dann
der öffentlichkeit vorzustellen
ich glaube sie kommt aus dieser aus
dieser situation nur raus wenn sie die
kontrolle nach außen abgibt wenn sie
unabhängige kommission an den start
bringt der kardinal ist doch in einer
verrückten rolle er ist auftraggeber
eines gutachtens was ihn möglicherweise
und seine vorgänger und seine
mitarbeiter belasten könnte und soll das
jetzt vorstellen
er ist letztlich in einer doppelten
rolle gefangen und das fällt ihm jetzt
auf die füße und das zeigt die
richter alleine mit sich selbst kann es
nicht sie braucht unterstützung und
hilfe von außen
sie muss sich aber auch helfen lassen
sie sprechen die situation in köln daher
kann sich das ist die widerstände
teilweise noch da sind ja genau der sie
sprechen die die missstände aus ihrer
sicht in köln an lassen sie uns dabei
doch gerne bleiben rainer maria woelki
der erzbischof von köln hat dieses
gutachten in auftrag gegeben er hat es
bis heute nicht veröffentlicht er sagt
wegen methodischen fehlern die externe
anwaltsfirma die sie ja schon
angesprochen haben die sagt sie habe
alle fälle untersucht 236 fälle seien
das gewesen sie habe aber eben nur die
wichtigsten 15 zusammengefasst wissen
sie mehr können sie uns erklären werde
in anführungszeichen recht hat nein das
kann ich nicht das kann niemand der die
das gutachten nicht kennt das ist ja die
verrückte situation wir sollen uns eine
meinung bilden über etwas was wir gar
nicht angeschaut haben
ich glaube der fehler ist schon am
anfang gemacht worden
der auftrag zu so einem gutachten zu so
einer untersuchung darf eben nicht von
den beschuldigten kommen um es mal
drastisch zu sagen sondern der muss
kommen von einem unabhängigen gremium
da müssen betroffene beteiligt werden
die dann zum beispiel auch vielleicht
eine einschätzung abgeben ob dieser oder
jener aspekt mehr beleuchtet werden muss
da müssen wissenschaftler mit an den
start und vor allem muss die finger
weglassen die kirche selber die
beschuldigten selber also diejenigen
denen möglicherweise fehlverhalten
vorzuwerfen ist und das geht hier nicht
um strafrechtliche dinge also niemand
wird danach ins gefängnis gehen das kann
man bedauern aber das ist so trotzdem
merkt man es fällt der kirche schwer
loszulassen das fällt insbesondere auch
in köln den verantwortlichen schwer
loszulassen und die kontrolle abzugeben
nach außen vielleicht nur kurz zum
abschluss dieses themas köln was würden
sie sich wünschen von rainer maria
woelki
ich habe ihn ja schon zum rücktritt
aufgefordert ich glaube das ist nur der
beginn eines weges ich glaube er muss
platz machen damit die gläubigen einen
neuanfang beginnen können
ich wünsche mir das sehr wünschen wir
dass vor allem für die menschen die so
enttäuscht sind von der situation und
ich hoffe dass er diese kraft findet und
nicht diesen elend langen prozess weiter
in die länge zieht
jetzt haben sie gesagt betroffene müssen
stärker eingebunden werden in die
bistümer limburg mainz und fulda haben
ja angekündigt sie wollen einen
sogenannten betroffenen beirat gründen
und haben betroffene explizit eingeladen
dort eben auch darüber zu sprechen wie
man in der kirche das ganze besser
öffentlich machen kann und darüber
sollte ja heute auch bei diesem
pressegespräch geben ist das aus ihrer
sicht ein schritt in die richtige
richtung
also der prozess dort läuft wie ich
finde recht gut und sie haben den
entscheidenden punkt genannt
betroffene sollen von anfang an
eingebunden werden das war auch bei dem
ganzen projekt bislang so wichtig ist
mir eigentlich nur der eine punkt
betroffene dürfen nicht das gefühl
bekommen instrumentalisiert zu werden
für die schadensbegrenzung in der kirche
das ist ja das was zum beispiel in köln
die mitglieder des betroffenen beirat
aus dem bistum vorwerfen
dazu ist es notwendig dass man den
betroffenen die man da einbeziehen will
und deren expertise man nutzen will
stärkt und ihnen bei der vernetzung und
beim austausch untereinander hilft da
ist noch viel luft nach oben
ich selbst weiß dass er zehn jahren bin
ich hier am start wir haben das alles
aus bordmitteln bisher gestimmt keine
unterstützung von keiner seite bekommen
weder vom staat noch von der kirche
das geht den anderen betroffenen
initiativen in hildesheim
münster in rheda in köln süddeutschland
genauso hier glaube ich muss man langsam
sehen dass die betroffenen da auch ein
eigenes standing brauchen damit sie an
diesen prozessen konstruktiv mitarbeiten
können das verstehe ich
dass sie fordern dass die kirche
explizit eben auch geld gibt für
betroffenen institutionen dass diese
eben auch selbst im zweifel ja
nachforschen können wenn man einen
gesprächspartner will auf augenhöhe wie
es immer so schön heißt dann muss ich
die voraussetzungen dafür schaffen und
ein weg wäre dass die kirche selber
unterstützung anbietet für die
betroffenen gruppen eine andere
möglichkeit wäre dass man mit dem staat
darüber spricht auch damit die
unabhängigkeit gewahrt ist dass das ja
auch eine gesellschaftlich notwendige
aufgabe ist die wir da leisten
aber wenn man augenhöhe will muss man
sie auch herstellen und dazu gehört eben
tatsächlich auch die selbstorganisation
und vernetzung von betroffenen zu
fördern
herr matschie deutsche bischofskonferenz
hat ja sehr öffentlichkeitswirksam klar
gemacht oder gesagt sie wird transparenz
ich zitiere das transparenz offenheit
und schonungslose aufklärung nun in der
zukunft gewährleisten jetzt ist nächste
woche ab dienstag die digitale
frühjahrsvollversammlung der deutschen
bischofskonferenz
was wünschen sie sich dass solche und
ähnliche erklärungen hören wir ja nun
schon seit sehr langer zeit ich glaube
ich wünsche mir dass die kirche der
politik ihren partnern in der politik
signalisiert dass sie bereit ist
unterstützung anzunehmen
ich glaube diese aufarbeitungsprozess
der jetzt in den verschiedenen bistümern
langsam anfängt nach dieser langen
vorlaufzeit braucht öffentliche
begleitung er braucht die unterstützung
durch kritische abgeordnete aus den
parlamenten
die diese aufarbeitung projekte
begleiten die zeit wo die kirche das mit
sich alleine ausmachen konnte
die müssen jetzt endlich vorbei sein und
ich hoffe dass die bischöfe über diese
frage miteinander sprechen werden in der
nächsten woche
georg bätzing der vorsitzende der
deutschen bischofskonferenz für die
ihnen wahrscheinlich sagen wir sind da
auf einem weg der augsburger geschichts
professor martin kaufhold der sich viel
mit epochenwandel beschäftigt hat der
sagt die
katholische kirche ist im ganzen bedroht
und wenn es so weiter geht dann gibt es
sie in 20 jahren nicht mehr
was sagen sie naja gut als ich bin jetzt
kein theologe um das zu beurteilen was
von dem jesus wort zu halten ist dass
sie nicht vergehen wird aber ich glaube
in der form wie wir sie kennen
in dieser hierarchischen männer
bündischen ja auch gewalttätigen
binnenstruktur hat sie keine zukunft
und daran muss sie arbeiten aber ich
glaube es gibt ganz viele katholikinnen
und katholiken die das genauso sehen und
die sich dafür auch einsetzen
die aufgabe für uns ist der
öffentlichkeit ist diese verbrechen der
vergangenheit aufzuklären und dafür zu
sorgen dass strukturen geschaffen werden
die verhindern dass sich so etwas in der
kirche wie auch sonst in der
gesellschaft wiederholen kann
matthias katsch der sprecher der
opferinitiative eckiger tisch über den
umgang der katholischen kirche mit
sexueller gewalt vielen dank herr karl
hierfür das für nichts tagesgespräch